by the power of castle hate skull i
you know i sang on a previous episode
and a lot of people apparently thought
i'm a good singer so i'm going to
incorporate more of my beautiful angel
voice into these episodes for you
because seriously you guys can recognize
talent okay and i don't mean to toot my
own horn but i do mean to blow my own
bugle and whatever you want to take away
from that metaphor is fine with me as
long as you understand that i'm going to
give the people what they want if it's
singing i'll sing
bet you didn't know i could hit those
high notes
actually this is a day today where my
voice is a little raspy i think i'm
getting sick
i could possibly have the vid sorry
casey sorry we're doing this
but
you're already sick dude um it's too
late you know what are you gonna do
let's move on move forward so i have
just got back from a chicago where i was
with brendan at his stand-up shows had a
great time you know a lot of people say
you got to go to this place you got to
go to that place you're in
texas oklahoma these states that are
kind of known for their food and
chicago is one of those places that's
internationally known for food and i
will say i think i had the best barbecue
that i've had
out of all the places that we go to
where people say you gotta try this
barbecue it's amazing and we have had
some amazing barbecue but i think this
place said i'm gonna i know i'm gonna
butcher the name i think it's green
street meats in chicago
if not it's green meats i think it's
green street meats
there we go okay it is green street
meats that place was amazing
the brisket i was trying to pick up the
brisket with a fork it's like falling
off they got great sauces they had uh
great desserts um
i met up with my buddy nash from
repworks we ate there he got bamboozled
into
eating the salmon who orders salmon
at a barbecue restaurant not me never
would i'm very conservative when it
comes to stuff like that are you like
that casey
like yeah it's like especially if you're
in like a new place it's like
get what their special thing is yes do
the thing you're supposed to do with the
place yeah because there's nothing worse
than like going to a place where they're
going to serve you a big portion and
it's like i don't even want to finish
this and i'm looking at everybody else
to me that's like one of my biggest
fears so i'm very conservative when it
comes to eating stuff at a restaurant
i'm always going to order this safe
stuff
and get satisfied and you know it
it wasn't lost on anyone at the table
that nash didn't finish
his salmon
let's see what else we also went to this
place called geno's
brandon was hyping up the
uh i think it's like filet mignon
sliders or something like that but they
were amazing
you know the best sliders i've had
the best french dip sandwich i've had so
i had a few
occasions where i said oh this is the
best thing of this thing that i've had i
had a just a regular cheese deep dish
pizza i've had other deep dish before
and i think it's really good but
you know this was really satisfying to
the point where you know you eat a
couple slices and you feel like you're
gonna throw up so obviously it's it's
very filling uh let's see what else
oh we went to this place wormhole coffee
which is like
uh an 80s themed coffee shop in chicago
that nash also put us onto
the drinks were good the decor was very
interesting they got a bunch of movie
posters you know like gremlins and
ghostbusters and back to the future they
had the uh delorean up on like a little
loft area so it was really decked out
really well themed but also kind of
you know it took so long to get to the
drinks it kind of makes you appreciate
starbucks because with these hipster
coffee joints it's kind of funny how the
stereotype
always seems to be true right
that uh you got these kind of
baristas with asymmetrical haircuts who
just seem really bothered to be there
it's like oh my god i have to make you a
drink they kept trying to get me to like
moving like yelling at us like through
masks like could everybody line up to
the left please please and i didn't
realize they were talking to me but it's
like you know um so there was like kind
of a hostile energy maybe to the you
know the fact that all these big dudes
walk in a coffee shop and or maybe i'm
just projecting that i never know but it
could be possible either way
the you know my vanilla latte took like
25 minutes to make and you go oh yeah
that's why people go to starbucks
because ultimately quality is not going
to be that important if you never get
your [ __ ] drink so
with that being said what's going on in
the news today we're actually doing
another episode where we film it on the
same day that we release it because of
the schedule that i've been uh having
these last couple weeks of traveling
we'll get back to normal soon but today
i get to talk about something that just
happened yes
and what just happened
will smith smacked chris rock at the
oscars and i
am gonna put this actually under uh one
of my favorite segments
celebrities are better than us uh
because apparently celebrities are
better than us because will smith could
assault a man on live tv and not get
arrested think about if i do that think
about if anybody else
who isn't an a-list celebrity did that
and what the repercussions might be
especially when it's televised and in
front of all those people at an event
where decorum uh is of prime importance
so i thought this was such an
interesting thing
to break down on a multitude of levels
the least of which being
whether or not it's fake because to me
it's so obviously fake just kidding it's
so obviously real but i've been posting
i went on a rampage you know if you
follow me you know i post a million
stories uh i posted 20 million stories
for this chris rock thing because
uh there is so many good memes right you
know they're coming out everywhere
everybody's contributing making both
jokes and memes and i find uh of the
vast majority of them hilarious and
share worthy now
one of the things that i posted
that led me
to want to make this the first angle
that i attack in dissecting this
and why am i spending time on it you
know i don't think that celebrity gossip
or
drama is that important and it's not
something i want to cover in the podcast
but what i do think is really
interesting is
the gender dynamics and the sort of uh
you know discussion around masculinity
and machismo and things that we've
discussed previously like you know my
fight from my almost fight from last
week and kind of you know what it means
when
adult men act out in these ways and
whether that's a sign of toughness or
standing up for your woman or emotional
fragility on the other hand um you know
i think there's arguments for both but i
just wanted to get my own personal take
on it before it becomes irrelevant
although i have a feeling this will
be something that we remember for a very
long time
possibly you know
the rest of history
because it's it was honestly one of the
most shocking things that i've ever seen
on live tv and i think anybody watching
you know would agree it's like you know
and maybe that's why people thought it
was fake because it's like it's hard to
wrap your mind around the idea that will
smith would slap chris rock on live tv
um for such a mile a seemingly mild joke
so the first thing i want to address is
is
it real because i posted a clip in slow
slo-mo that was actually somebody going
in case you think it's fake here's the
slap in slo-mo
and i think you can see the hand connect
and chris's reaction to it right
zoomed in and at a slower speed
for whatever reason i got a lot of
people reacting to that specifically
saying
um well you can see that he braces for
it right you can see chris rock bracing
for it and therefore you know it's fake
and so i got into it with a few people
at some point i was just like let me
just literally copy and paste like you
know or send you screenshots of the
previous argument i've had because i'm
going to say all the same things
but
the idea that you
first of all would lean in you can see
chris rock's body language that he's
leaning in it looks like he's going to
uh
he he anticipates will smith whispering
something to him that's what i took away
from him he like leans forward and he
thinks will smith's gonna say something
to him um
because he's heading if you wanted to
yell something obviously he would have
stayed in the seat right so it's like
i'm gonna come up and be like hey don't
do that or i'm gonna make a joke about
you or something of that nature and who
knows i'm not chris rock i have no idea
what he was anticipating but it didn't
look like he was going let me put my
chin out for you to slap
will slaps him really fast he didn't
telegraph it at all and
if you slow down you see that chris only
starts to move his head out of the way
at the very last second like within a
millisecond right
and
to me that's indicative of a normal
human reaction
that he sees it coming
and gets out of the way here we go
boom okay walks up
only when he sees our move you know like
but up until that very point that's a
millisecond that he has to respond so
i'm just of the idea that
when somebody gets that close to you and
raises their hand you instinctively know
that oh this person is going to attack
me and he moves a little bit but still
not quickly enough to move out of the
way i had a boxer in my dms a
quote-unquote boxer and his argument was
sort of i've been in more fights than
you uh you know therefore i'm an expert
on people getting hit or hitting
and i'm like oh my god you know this is
uh
you know an appeal to authority fallacy
you don't know anything about uh you
know somebody getting slapped in this
incident and whether it's fake or not
just based on the fact that you've had
many fights
and uh and his solution to our
disagreement was also like well let's
fight then like cool
mixed rules
do i get to take you down
he was like no you got to cut down to
170 and then box me i'm like sounds good
dude that will definitely happen uh but
obviously if you're in an argument with
somebody and you feel the need to resort
to being like
let's box about it to solve this
disagreement over what happened at the
oscars you might be in the in the losing
category for this argument
now
the other thing
is
because you know i think if you really
dissect that you're going to see that
yes chris rock really got slapped he
wasn't anticipating it but that's not
the important thing to hone in on
there's context before and there's uh
context after that really signifies that
this was real the context before is
everything that will smith has been
going through that would lead him to be
in a very emotional place beforehand and
also the context of will smith making uh
or sorry
jada pinkett boycotting the oscars in
2016
and will smit chris rock making jokes
about that at her expense i think the
joke was
that's like me boycotting rihanna's
panties because she wasn't in a movie
that was nominated for an oscar so you
know she wasn't invited i guess is the
logic so why would she be going she
probably took offense to that um but it
was ironic because
there's clips of her saying
i don't even care what anybody says
about my head all i can do is laugh at
this point so she's making this big
public spectacle out of everything uh
and putting
her baldness in her quote-unquote
medical condition out into the the
public and saying that she doesn't care
what people think about it um and that
could also be true because let's analyze
like why he slapped
or how you could get into the psychology
of will smith
smacking chris rock
will smith um
has been publicly emasculated by his
wife for the past year because she went
on
her podcast and talked about having an
entanglement with one of her kids
friends i guess like this guy
august alcina who's
a 20 something
she went ahead and made that public and
made that discussion public by going on
her podcast about it and we got to see
will smith cry on camera we got to see
him
uh seemingly be humiliated for this guy
who's an a-list movie star somebody who
represents the sort of you know
prototypical black alpha male uh for him
to be
uh cocked by a younger guy i mean it's
sort of the stuff of nightmares for a
lot of men in that position that you
would be embarrassed in that way and i'm
not sure what the exact dynamic of their
relationship is or what they agreed to
but they didn't make that part public
they just made the part public where uh
you know he's
he's getting to hear about this affair
right so
and it wasn't just that it was the
response to it that he's the recipient
of all these memes and
jokes and you know that information is
everywhere and uh you know you're a guy
who's
built your entire career over the course
of decades of being the man
and then in some ways it's easy to see
how you would feel like that was all
kind of
taken away from you or undermined
because of your wife's
behavior and again i don't know what's
going on between them but they did make
that public information and you can
imagine how that might make a man
feel a lot of pent-up emotions
maybe not even you know
towards other people making the memes
maybe towards jada maybe towards august
maybe towards
uh you know many different people who he
feels he can't act out at like that now
that plays a part in what we see because
he seemingly laughs at the joke at first
and then
goes on to see that his wife has this
stink face reaction to it right that
she's sort of like rolls her eyes
and i assume that triggered something in
him that his wife isn't happy maybe she
even said something i don't know but
uh
maybe it reminded him of calm maybe he
laughed like instinctively like you know
like you hear the cadence of a joke and
you laugh and then maybe it sinks in
that this is not cool and then you see
your wife's not happy um so i think with
that information you can see how if
you're already emotionally on edge just
like this guy with the golf club or
whatever i don't know what's going on in
his life for that thing to trigger him
getting a golf club and trying to hit me
but obviously there was a lot that went
into that moment that was beyond this
situation but that that provided the
spark for it right so
you have to assume that was just the
right spark to do something super
irrational because it doesn't benefit
him in any way right and there's a lot
of people saying
he's doing it for publicity
uh he's doing to get attention it's you
know people are talking about it blah
blah blah the oscars ratings are failing
and chris rock's tour is going to be you
know it's selling way more tickets and
it's like i just don't think
you do there's so many other ways to do
that the oscars aren't dependent on the
broadcast to survive will smith's career
isn't dependent on getting you know ex
more exposure than him winning the oscar
being nominated for it all these things
just don't really add up as true
motivations to
fake something but you can see how how
men act irrationally
when they're humiliated and sort of
desperately
grab on to uh things that they think
could sort of
get that back and so i think in his mind
he was like reasserting
uh you know his his dominance his
masculinity whatever you want to say
about that
um and afterwards is another indicator
that
this isn't fake you see that chris rock
is totally flustered by it right
chris rock has this emotional response
to what had just happened you can see
him searching for his words he's
flustered he says uh we're here to
present a documentary we're here to
present an award for document i mean
this is a guy who talks for a living on
stage every single night for decades
he's a man who knows the importance of
linguistic precision and he's mixing up
his word even though it's a small thing
you can tell he's flustered will smith
is saying yelling
keep your name your wife keep my wife's
name out of your effing mouth yells it
twice as loud as he can right you hear
that you hear the guy's voice you're
like oh
that dude is screaming and that dude is
making everyone around him uncomfortable
even though people might be laughing i
assume it's laughing out of discomfort
or maybe they assumed it was a prank too
and then they're realizing it's not i
mean
i just you know if you look at that and
think the emotional reactions are fake
or acted i think you're vastly
overestimating even the skill of will
smith and the willingness to make other
people uncomfortable uh that that will
smith would would uh actually do because
he's not a troll if it was like an andy
kaufman type thing or somebody who's a
you know professional troll sure
but i think it's a really interesting
thing to look at you know as far as
it's another example where i go man
emotional self-discipline i don't think
it's a manly thing to do and i don't
think that his wife needed to be stood
up for in that instance because
if she had cancer and she was bald
uh and chris rock makes a joke like hey
look your hair is gone and next year
you'll be gone too or something of that
nature back whoa what the you know yeah
sure i could totally understand you
getting up and smacking a dude for being
like my wife's dead next year her joke
but in this context he made a comparison
to a
sexy lead female in a movie that was
like really popular in demi moore at the
time was this like
you know v sex symbol of hollywood and
she's a badass who had a shaved head so
the comparison is very flattering even
though it's a joke it's like
if you look at really what the joke is
saying it's so mild and tepid
that you know you know she wanted to
have an eye roll at that shirt but she's
also been on record saying it doesn't
bother me when people talk about this so
um it just wasn't the joke that i think
is worthy you know all not all jokes
were equal it wasn't the joke worthy of
assaulting another man on stage and then
finally you ask yourself the question
would you have done it if it was a
larger dude would have done it if it was
someone his size or who he he thought
might have fought back
uh you know like the rock or somebody
much larger than him or somebody you
know an mma fighter who's not as big as
him but who could defend himself i don't
think it would and that kind of makes it
a [ __ ] move to me and a bully move
because you're attacking somebody who
you're guessing won't fight back so
that's all i have to say about that
masculine
nope i think it would have been much
more masculine to
hold it in let the show go on and
confront him later about it if you were
still angry about it maybe ask him to
make an apology
you know put this lashing out and then
you know
talking about non-violence later i don't
know i just
i think you got to grow up at some point
and just
never do stuff like that because it just
shows
that you're but you know hey you're in
pain and i don't i don't blame him for
having a lot of those feelings i just
think that you know and people say
violence never the answer sometimes it
is if people are committing violence
against you or they cross certain lines
sure i can justify that but
in this instance i just don't think it
was
the right thing to do and there's a
million memes you're gonna see on my
page one that i thought was amazing this
morning was
this one right here
chris rock makes joke will smith smack
jada and it's fire marshall bill with
the hair sticking out everywhere
boom roasted wow guess who's still using
kratom every time he does this podcast
he's got two thumbs and gigantic muscles
it's me well
i have to encourage you once again to
try out kratom
if you haven't already and if you have
keep buying it because the stuff is good
and guess what you use it in moderation
you're firing up your brain you're
feeling really fantastic on this stuff
but not just any brand of kratom we're
using happy hippocratum because that is
the highest quality kratom available
on earth
i repeat the highest quality kratom
known to man on earth perhaps there's
other higher quality kratom somewhere
else in the solar system or universe but
if we're talking about on this planet on
this planet right here
always happy hippo so i want y'all to go
to happyhippo.com
happyhippo herbals.com and use promo
code thickboy with 3cs for 20 off and
don't think that's just a one-time thing
that you use 20 off
you do it every time
again and again and again for the rest
of your life okay
enjoy okay we got the liver king meme of
the week
when you when you successfully troll
uh a million plus followers into
thinking eating testicles gets you
jacked and not taking copious amounts of
d-ball boom
and this is actually a video a short
little video where he's going
amazing
the memes don't stop because we love the
liver king
and i'm going to try to include them
every single week we got a mark harley
mean of the week we had a couple of them
after the story last week we got nathan
christie baird
with a tweet
he also posted this on ig but i know i
could find it more easily on twitter
it's a drawing of me
looking super jacked dude
just uh bendy what kind of golf club is
that casey
like that appears to be a short iron i'd
say between an eight iron and a wedge
okay
eight iron wedge we don't know we're
gonna have to ask him what he based it
on but obviously i'm out uh
on the green
just taking this uh golf club
bending it into a pretzel because i am
so strong i'm able to do that with ease
and the face i'm making isn't even
exertion it's just like
[Music]
like i'm having fun
great job with this you guys are so
creative you came up with that really
quickly actually after the episode
dropped uh good for you and then we'll
do a link right under that
this dude adam mentality who makes a lot
of great memes
let's turn the volume up on that he took
my voice and put it over the classic
he-man opening
the power of castle aids goal i am hella
mark harley
amazing perfect again i appreciate it
guys this kind of stuff is it's so tight
all right
you know i wanted to jump to uh before
we do this like we can't have nice gyms
i wanted to do a help i'm on steroids
and this week we're gonna be talking
about hgh which uh is it a anabolic
steroid no it's not but it's in that
general class of substances and i've
just been getting a lot of
questions recently on it and how to get
it is it worth it what's the cost
how should i take it
it's something that i've experimented
with before in the past and i'm actually
running it now and i plan on running it
when i do my a cruising on about 200
milligrams of testosterone in between
any sort of larger cycles that i may do
which i'm doing right now i'm cruising
on 200 and i'm going to take
between four to six iu's of hgh a day
i'm going to talk about my experiences
and answer some of the questions that
people have asked me
about sort of how to procure it
uh what it does to you whether it's real
or fake or worth the money all these
different things so
first and foremost if you're interested
in getting it you can get it off the
dark web uh you know there are some i've
used various vendors to get it
um
i've accidentally bought some fake stuff
it was like from german
labs i think and um
like i looked it up online and some
people said you know like the brand is
like german labs it looks legit but then
i looked it up online and people were
testing their own igf levels
insulin like growth factor
and that would be an indicator after you
take it those levels should spike and
there was nothing happening so obviously
it's fake right
um
pharmaceutical grade growth hormone is
super expensive
and
just not worth it at that point you know
it could be like thousands of dollars a
month potentially depending on how much
you use but a kit of generic
blue tops
quote-unquote they're just like little
bottles a kit is um 10 bottles that have
10 ius of powder in them uh that you mix
with a milliliter of water or however
you want to mix it but you know it's a
hundred ius of growth hormone are in a
kit quote-unquote
the the blue tops are generics that come
from china and they're more affordable
um
there's a debate out there on whether or
not
you know
pharmaceutical grade is is better
with some of these things it's like is
it the substance or not because if it's
chemically the same i don't know how you
can make an improvement on it you know
what i mean it's like
you know it's not like oh this is a
certain kind of beef that's like you
know
leaner or but you know like beef isn't
always beef is it grass-fed is it you
know grass finished does it if this and
that is the way it's prepared and raised
and all these different things i'm just
making that analogy to be like there's
these qualitative differences
depending on all these circumstances
with a chemical it's like is it lsd or
not you know what i mean is it alcohol
or not so that's why i'm always
skeptical to people like brown alcohol
does this to me and then like you know
beer does this and it's like well aren't
you like getting intoxicated the same
exact way from the same exact chemical
so i tend to lean towards that side of
things with hgh like is it hgh or not if
it's hgh then it should all be the same
it might be under dose that could be one
thing but um
you know i i
i don't really give a [ __ ] because i'm
not going to be spending thousands of
dollars a month on
any form of performance enhancing drug
um you know no matter how powerful it is
and hgh isn't known as being something
that's super powerful it's being it's
known as something that might have
muscle building effects might have
hyperplasia effects and hyperplasia is
the
splitting of muscle cells to make
additional muscle cells i think it's
been proven that that happens in animals
but not necessarily in humans it's just
theorized too and that gets thrown
around a lot
that oh yeah it causes hyperplasia i
don't know if it does i don't think
there's actually any concrete evidence
that it builds muscle it's possible but
to my knowledge there hasn't been any
you know serious double-blind scientific
studies that document an increase in
lean tissue beyond
water weight gain
uh you know over time so who knows it's
a question mark
what is well documented is its fat loss
properties that it does shift your body
into
um
lipolysis at greater rates compared to
for example
um
you know without growth hormone you're
going to be using uh you're going to be
primarily using carbohydrates as a fuel
source
and
ostensibly
hgh causes you to start to burn more fat
as your primary fuel source now i have
taken hgh many times between two to four
inch units a day i'm taking up to six
now
uh i do notice fat burning effects and i
do notice fullness and vascularity okay
um and i know for a fact that
i've taken generic stuff that's real
because one of the things that happens
is you get carpal tunnel because of some
of this water retention like yeah your
arms like in the middle of the night
your arms this didn't happen to me but
then like i'd wake up and my arms would
be numb and that's the supposed side of
so it's like you know be pretty random
if i just started taking growth hormone
now i'm getting carpal tunnel kind of
you know the tingling sensations numbing
in my arms when i sleep
and i would take that as a pretty solid
sign as you're gonna get i didn't test
my igf-1 levels but you know i did
notice the cosmetic effects of growth
hormone people will often you know come
to me saying is this
something i should do on its own and i'm
like
i think it has a lot of synergistic
properties with at least testosterone
i've had great results from 150
milligrams of test you know and
two to four uh ius of hgh a day and you
can even cycle on and cycle off like
during the week like do five or six days
and take a day off to make it last a
little bit longer the theory being that
you um you know re-sensitize
your uh
i believe it's the you know igf-1 or
insulin receptors
i forget exactly what it is but there is
a logic behind it that you should and
perhaps it's just even
your own hgh production that people say
you could potentially be stunting but
i'm not too sure on the hard science of
that it's it's to my knowledge it's more
just like you know they theorize you
should do that
i've purchased hgh anywhere the blue
tops anywhere from 150 to 250 per 100
ius it's still relatively cheap at 250
um
per 100 ius because if you're using two
iu's a day which is a dose that will
cause fat loss
that's gonna last you about seven weeks
and even more if you take a day off
right um or you could spend that a month
right at 150 it's easier to justify you
know maybe taking three every day and
that lasts you about 100 iu's last a
month um
i was going to say
what is scientifically proven is that
the fat burning benefits max out at
about 1.5 iu's per injection and that
lasts about eight hours so in theory you
could take
4.5 ius a day and get the maximal fat
burnings from you know taking
an injection of 1.5 i use every 8 hours
on the dot
but taking more than that at what time
does not increase the fat burning
effects it may or may not have an effect
on muscle building effects uh
and lots of bodybuilders are known to
take copious amounts of hgh some people
theorize that hgh and insulin produce
that gut that you see in bodybuilding um
it definitely will make you more full um
you know and the theory behind hgh
causing bubble gut is the idea that it
makes all everything grow
and it's possible my head has gotten
bigger since using it because this is
a uh a larger cap than i've ever worn
you know like and i know like at some
point i could fit into like a seven and
a quarter when i was a teenager and then
seven and three eighths was like a
little big and you know so i don't know
if that's normal growth but like
even as of like last year i think this
is like one like an eighth bigger than i
normally wear so i don't know have you
has your hat size changed over the years
it certainly hasn't and i was gonna say
what are you wearing now like a 20 21.
seven and five eighths so i think i had
like a seven and a half before and then
i put that i'm like oh that doesn't fit
you know and because like it's kind of
like these areas like the soft areas of
your head that are supposedly like would
expand from that in your jaw um i don't
know but you do see people who
supposedly abuse hgh like remember david
boston
no okay we was this
really interesting like story
um
he was this nfl player who's like this
receiver and he got up like 260 pounds
but kept getting injured he was like
super skinny but then had these like
kind of secretive like he just like kind
of became obsessed with getting jacked
and it was like just became like
monstrous now obviously he has like top
tier amazing genetics but
it like interfered with how he was
playing because he kept getting injured
and he was had this kind of like guru
guy who was doing all these uh
you know
like
he'd do like a nightly like iv with him
and he'd be like oh no it's just like
vitamins and minerals like they knew he
was doing the iv but then
you know it's like ah interesting you're
doing this nightly iv that's definitely
not steroids and all of a sudden you
gained like 60 pounds of muscle over the
course of how many years i don't think
it was that rapid but still like he was
the size of like a defensive end you
know at like five percent body fat and
just didn't work out for him but he was
also like the tail was also interesting
because he was
he became more narcissistic as he also
was gaining this weight and
they they interviewed some girls who
said he would like hit on them at bars
by like giving them a shirtless picture
of himself
he would just like walk up and be like
this is me and it'd have his number on
it it'd just be like him posing
shirtless and i'm like hey that's not a
bad idea
whatever works yeah just put my ig on
there you know hello mark harley what's
up come get it i was gonna ask does if
you notice your head is getting bigger
does that
deter me no no but does it
make you at all scared or trepidatious
in any way it it doesn't maybe it should
but i'm just being honest that like if
my head's getting bigger
i'm not scared uh it's
it's something that
the heart enlargement i know like i've
taken echocardiograms before and
apparently i do have a somewhat enlarged
heart you know
you're a caring guy
does that mean yeah my heart's enlarged
it's just because i care so much i'm
basically a care bear now
yeah that doesn't bother me as much like
because i know some of these things can
be counteracted with having a high
cardiovascular capacity so i make sure
to run hills for example on a regular
interval my cardio is not the best it's
ever been right now but i would like to
eventually get to a place where i'm like
230 pounds right i don't actually have a
desire to like now i am bigger and
stronger than i have been you know
in the past
but
i don't want to do that endlessly i do
feel like there's a sweet spot for me
around like 230 240 pounds at least for
the foreseeable future and after that at
some point you got to lean up and you
know take the stress off your heart but
in the meantime i think a lot of
bodybuilders run into issues because
they're focusing all their efforts on
high intensity weightlifting and do very
low intensity cardio so it's a lot of
walking a lot of stuff that like
doesn't really stress their heart in the
way that they should but greg giuset for
example is a big advocate of
doing like he bikes every day he does
like a stationary bike type like a
peloton or something similar and he like
races people so he's like like an elite
like racer
and i think that's one of these elements
of longevity where it's like if you can
make your heart really strong in your
cardiovascular system really strong
you're probably going to avoid in
addition to like you know that's that's
uh you know a great workout for your
legs which is also key you know muscle
mass correlates with not having dementia
and alzheimer's in old age i forget if
we've talked about that or not but
that's one of these really interesting
things that kind of
sounds crazy like what leg muscle mass
you know like predicts whether or not
you have dementia but what it really
means is are you sedentary you know have
you lost all your leg muscle by the time
that you're you know an octogenarian
um because you don't do anything and
think about what that correlates with
you're probably eating crappy or you're
probably
um just not taking care of yourself in
general
um but they call alzheimer's and
dementia diabetes of the brain
so is that have we discussed this enough
you get the picture with the hgh
do you want to make your head bigger
then take hgh now go to lralabs.com not
serious go to lra labs.com if you want
both post psychotherapy because this is
important right people are always asking
me like
you know how do i get off of steroids
what do i do after you have to take
clomid hcg and perhaps you can switch
out climate for novidex but the easy
thing to do is take a double dose of
clomid you know uh
every day for a week and then go back to
one dose for another week that's the
most simple protocol there's there's
many available but you know that'll get
things started again i'm doing that
right now yes my nuts are already bigger
um you can actually if it's kind of
crazy you can feel it like
they double in size go if like if you've
been on cycle for a few months um
you know they don't get tiny but you can
just notice like an atrophy you know
it's almost like a muscle being pumped
or not it's like oh that seems full and
large
um
and but the hcg i think is one of the
the main things that really causes it to
get bigger okay
this is why we can't have nice this
isn't a serious stuff for now all right
somebody said hey this is you
this dude is [ __ ] hilarious 705
pounds skateboard deficit jefferson
reverse band chain loaded 52 card pickup
deadlift so does he have cards in his
mouth is that is that what's going on
that's hilarious he's got the chains and
this is actually an impressive lift even
though it's banded
uh he's probably still you know
deadlifting on a skateboard like or
sorry a a jefferson uh deadlift which is
between your legs at least 600 pounds it
looks tough and the balance aspect of
like digging your feet in to actually do
a deadlift that's
you know one of the hardest things and
what you you know why people do like
flat shoes or
nose shoes i really like nose shoes to
really feel the ground and get a stable
surface he has an incredibly unstable
surface and he's still able to lift it
up so this is hilarious i love the fact
that he's doing this in his home because
it's like
this is why we can have nice gyms
because if you want to do some crazy
[ __ ] you do it in your own home
what's the next one here okay
pov you arrive at the gym but it's push
day and the the door says pull
cut to
car driving through the [ __ ] window
it's amazing because somebody actually
did that even though it's a joke and the
guy who's posting it didn't you know
drive through the window
imagine you're on the treadmill and a
car just like bolts through the [ __ ]
the the glass and almost kills you
hilarious glad no one got hurt all right
we got a classic slappy in the face
people are still doing these banded
things like without tying it down it's
like what do you what do you have under
there clearly it was like a chair
holding it down or something that was
totally insufficient that's dangerous
though it makes me think of this one
time
i went wakeboarding with my little
brother and uh
he was in the boat and i like
i fell and held on to the
handle a little bit too long and there
was like this elasticity
and let go because i was like really i
hadn't gotten up here so i was really
trying to get up get up get up and
another part of it was like i was in a
speedo that i made into a thong because
we're like gonna make like a you know
a prank by like going by the shore and
like having my ass out right
all fun and games until somebody loses
an eye literally
andy didn't lose an eye but the elastic
thing came back in the boat he had
sunglasses on luckily otherwise it could
have been much worse but it like
exploded the sunglasses hit him right in
the eye
i came up under the boat i'm like oh my
god he lost his eye he was wailing he
had blood dripping from his face it was
like a severe injury and he still has
like his pupil dilated thanks older
brother right you know
mr remind i know it's a very dark story
i'm making light of it i think we've
come to terms with it but it was a very
very dark day and it just makes me think
about stuff like this because like oh
elastic slapped in the face but it's
like if that hits you in the eye at the
right angle that's going very fast and
your eyes are very sensitive organs so
watch out
all right we got here
a little kitty in the backpack why are
you taking your cat to the gym i mean i
guess it's not the worst thing in the
world but i would never
think to do that because the cat doesn't
want to be there
why don't you just leave it at home cats
love being home or they love walking
around but do they like being in a
crowded gym
on the treadmill bouncing up around as
it's trying to clean itself probably not
so hey don't do that
and do we have one more
okay then we can go on
to
this bro science academy i love this
guy's channel okay
uh
and it's just gonna be a screenshot here
uh high intensity health is the channel
this is a guy who's got great scientific
about many things his his videos are
concise they're long but they do get a
lot of information out in the time that
they run and he references a lot of
studies he's really good about that and
the best i can do is sort of regurgitate
the main points but the title of the
video is exercise drops blood sugar and
insulin fast and primes fat burning so
what was my takeaway from this if you
have high blood sugar uh
exercise
can solve that
right and if you have a metabolic
disease of some sort
like diabetes uh you know exercise is
often the cure it's as simple as that
and it goes into sort of what happens on
the cellular level and my takeaway was
exercise almost makes it like
your your
cells are more thirsty for glycogen
right they prime them to be more thirsty
for glycogen more more ready to suck
that in and take sugar out of your
bloodstream and into the muscle so it
primes them to do that more efficiently
and
that
you know
makes your
basically makes your muscles more
insulin sensitive you want insulin
sensitivity not insulin insensitivity
because when you're insulin insensitive
then
insulin is being released and you need
more of it to
for it to do its job of ushering these
nutrients uh and specifically you know
sugar carbohydrates et cetera into the
muscle cell in the form of glycogen so
uh it's it's an important thing
that has a very simple answer apparently
and there was some interesting studies
that he references like
uh they're doing leg extensions you do
one leg and then the other and then like
this leg like glycogen is uploaded into
the muscles after a few sets of you know
it's like it's more primed even in the
same body which is like sort of the
ultimate like test it's like half of
your body is like they were the same
person same circumstances except one
variable which is you know one side did
leg extensions and one didn't and then
you saw how the muscle cells reacted on
a cellular level to these two different
uh to the the same stimulus um
the same amount of insulin being
released and what that did so ultimately
uh he also recommends things like
uh you know taking a walk after you eat
um insulin
and or blood sugar levels would be
peaking
i think he said 45 to 60 minutes after a
meal so like imagine you finish your
meal and a lot of people do this anyway
let's go for a walk turns out that's a
really good thing to do because um
rather than keeping your blood sugar
high throughout the night
you can load those nutrients into your
muscle cells and lower your blood sugar
before you go to bed with something like
you know a short walk of 20 minutes or
whatever it's just a healthy practice
that uh you know will increase your
health in a really simple way that
actually probably feels good as well and
um you know also that
you know
it he talks about the two different
things you can achieve with
either doing cardio fasted or using like
an intra-workout carbohydrate
intra-workout carbohydrate would be
great if you're trying to make gains if
you're trying to optimize
performance during a workout have the
carbs in the middle of the workout
working out fasted
does prime your body
for fat loss more and i know that's kind
of an age-old debate of like does fasted
cardio
uh
do more as far as fat loss a lot of
people will say no it doesn't doesn't
matter it just matters like the caloric
sort of balance at the end of the day or
end of the week whatever that's gonna
determine fat loss but this
video seemingly makes an argument for
the idea that fasted cardio does in fact
prime your body uh when you don't have
any carbohydrates in your body
immediately before you're gonna burn
more fat hella personality portion of
the podcast with an estb it's the very
bottom there
been meaning to do this okay
you know what i love estps uh estps
are entrepreneurs and a couple people
that are close to me
isaiah miranda is an estp tested and
verified and i also think gianni is an
estp just based on my observations
of him and also how well he gets along
with isaiah if you don't know gianni
he's uh the star of the power branch off
what's called ghost
the
series
we have no idea no um power book ghost
or something like that because it's like
the story of uh ghost sun and they both
get into drug leaning together
um
awesome show by all means do i watch it
no uh will i at some point yes johnny
i'm really sorry but um
i've historically got along really as an
entp i get along really well with estps
because they're very action oriented and
where i tend to maybe overthink things
and get in my head want to have like a
perfect plan or a perfect creation
before i put it out to the world estps
are very encouraging when it comes to
like let's do it let's spring into
action even if it's not perfect let's
make it happen and put it out so that's
like
a good
you know nudge to have and i also
they're also really good collaborators
because they encourage brainstorming and
things like that um and and they're
really good at like riffing with a
personality type like me so i'm gonna
read this entrepreneurs always have an
impact on their immediate surroundings
the best way to spot them at a party is
to look for the whirling eddy of people
flitting about them as they move from
group to group laughing and entertaining
with a blunt and earthly humor
entrepreneur personalities love to be
the center of attention if an audience
member is asked to come on stage
entrepreneurs volunteer or volunteer a
shy friend
theory abstract concepts and plotting
discussions about global issues and
their implications don't keep
entrepreneurs interested for long so
that's true the s versus the n component
of our similar personality types mean i
like abstraction i like discussing
things to death entrepreneurs are like
dude we don't need that let's just do it
and in many cases that's helpful
sometimes it's not sometimes you do need
to talk things out but um i like a
little push in that direction sometimes
entrepreneurs keep their conversations
energetic with a good dose of
intelligence but they like to talk about
what is or better yet to just go out and
do it entrepreneurs leap before they
look fixing their mistakes as they go
rather than sitting idle preparing
contingencies and escape clauses and i'm
just going to comment on that real quick
because
that's one of the things like you know
i'll use isaiah as an example
over the past year he's made tremendous
progress as an actor and only recently
started taking acting classes um i think
you know i love the skits we do together
we often come together and it's like all
right we're gonna do i know we're gonna
do a skit
um we don't do much planning we maybe
have a premise but we get together and
just work it out on the spot and that's
a very useful exercise for me because
i've left my own devices i'm like you
know i have to write it out and it has
to be perfect and i gotta workshop the
jokes and well you know and i'm gonna
add steps to it to sort of like ensure
the abstract perfection that will get in
the way of actually having real world
quality because it's never going to come
out right so getting together with
somebody like that who's like let's just
meet up we'll figure it out there it can
be kind of stressful when you do it
first but then you get better at it
and
getting in those reps as they're saying
it's like go out and do it uh leap
before you look that is one of these
approaches to get better at almost
anything is just get out of your head
and do it and do it a thousand times and
pretty soon you're gonna have a great
skill set so i've watched isaiah evolve
as a performer who now kind of directs
and acts in his own stuff he's doing
commercials for brands that are really
interesting that i've been a part of the
magic spoon one most recently that you
can look up on his uh youtube channel
and you know it's it's a great energy to
be around uh because they're doers and
yes i think to be an entrepreneur i
think all types could be an entrepreneur
they're using esdps as an example of uh
the entrepreneur archetype because you
kind of always have to be both
moving and doing everything it doesn't
really stop your job doesn't stop so you
always have to have this high energy
and i like to nap more you know what i
mean
but if you talk to a guy like isaiah or
another estp
there's always this discomfort with like
not doing he's like if i don't do
something today i don't feel good like i
don't feel like i did you know so he's
like he they
you know like a shark that kind of like
they have to be in motion at a certain
speed is that true about sharks i don't
know i just heard it one time
they can't go below a certain speed
right
and let's go some of the famous estps
down there
here we go ernest hemingway jack
nicholson eddie murphy madonna
who else we got
uh bruce willis
michael j fox
nicholas sarkozy samuel l jackson
jamie lannister yep i remember typing
him because i was like this dude's a man
of action he's like smooth he's charming
he also loves uh fighting and
competition that's another thing about
estbs they're very competitive they turn
everything into a game uh hank schrader
of breaking bad that's interesting i
wouldn't have typed him as an estp
um
lincoln bros no idea seth grayson i
remember that guy from house of cards
and no idea who gabriel solis is
all right ant-man no i
you know another person that i was going
to say is not listed on there but donald
trump is supposedly an estp and kanye
west as an estp
uh pt barnum was supposedly in the stp
these are people who like enjoy
self-promotion also to agree not every
uh personality type is comfortable with
that kind of thing being like yo yo i'm
the best you know i can do this better
than anyone else
give me the ball put me in coach um
but you need an element to that and like
so everybody could obviously learn to
self-promote it's just i think estps are
are okay being like yo come to this
thing tonight it's going to be the best
thing ever this is going to be the best
sketch ever you know this is going to be
the greatest presidency ever
and don't have any shame about it and
you know again it's a good skill to have
sometimes if you're a narcissistic
egomaniac it can be
a little too much and you over promise
and under under deliver but uh you know
on the whole
estps are great i don't have anything
bad to say about any personality types
right i love them all and you can see
that with my enthusiasm
and you know what i'll be honest with
you i did come straight from working out
today okay
i did um
do a bunch of sled pushes and pull-ups
and say
do i need to grab that
outfit that i had
in the car ready to go or am i going to
give this to you straight
unfiltered sweat still under my armpits
missed under my cap goes to chicago once
becomes a cubs fan i'm announcing it
right now okay
i am the biggest chicago cubs fan in
this room right now
is that true or not casey that's true
that's true only true statements on this
show
chicago i love you i'll be back good
night